this morning you spoke of the Cosmic
Christ as reality or something like that
would you please say more about that
because Cosmic Christ has always struck
me as very triumphant Christian
imperialism that's clearly not how your
use no no not at all no remember when I
said that this notion of Christ is not
in competition with anything because it
includes everything all right that's why
I say the Christ symbol is not now
limited to the Jewish Jesus which did I
all be very Orthodox
I still believe Jesus is the image of
the invisible God I still believe in the
divinity of Christ if you stay with me
you'll find out I'm quite conservative
all right and ironically it's that
conservative holding on to the
essentials the essentials which allows
me to blow the whole thing wide open if
you keep it there so the Cosmic Christ
is as soon as matter and spirits became
one now we are the first generation that
has a word for that we now call it the
Big Bang we even give a date to it
fourteen point six billion some say
thirteen point eight that God decided it
seems and here time falls apart I don't
know if time even means anything but God
decided to show himself herself itself
to manifest the innards of God and
that's creation so the early Franciscans
insisted that the first Bible was
creation and now that is in Romans 1:20
if you want to check it out that is in
the Bible the everything you need to
know is in the created universe and they
said that if we if we didn't respect the
first Bible created world we didn't
learn how to contemplatively honor
animals and plants and waters and skies
and this magnificence that surround us
every day we would murder and mangle the
second book the second book is that
maybe a little over two
years old but the first Bible is 14
billion years old
that's the Cosmic Christ so Jesus is the
personification this is Christian belief
if you're not Christian you don't have
to believe it yet if coheres though it
holds a lot together
Jesus is the personification in a moment
of time when we were ready for an I
violation ship I think when
consciousness had evolved enough that we
could fall in love with something
somebody he became the human eyes and
face of this infinite eternal Christ
which is creation
so the Cosmic Christ is saying as
Colossians and Ephesians say the Christ
existed from all eternity
Jesus was created in a moment of time
Christ is creation part of what you're
saying yes not part yeah that's it and
that's a lot if if if any of you think
I'm I'm making less of Jesus you're not
hearing me if you think I'm taking away
your Jesus this makes Jesus far more
central the Alpha and the Omega
you know of history that's saying here's
where it came from
divine love and here's where we return
to divine love as taylored says the
Christ stands at the end of history
seducing it forward into love hmm good
stuff back here